hey everyone I'm Liana gelareh and Ichi
is coming at you live from Comic Con and
I'm so excited because right now I'm
joined by the new cast of Nancy Drew hi
guys happy first comic-con
how are you feeling right now it's a
little bit of an overwhelming process I
am so excited for the fans to be able to
see Nancy Drew on their screens this
October I'm very fortunate I've already
seen the pilot and it's so much fun I
have so many questions first off Kennedy
stepping into the iconic shoes of Nancy
Drew an amazing literary figure what was
your initial reaction when you found out
you got the role I actually I mean when
I found out I was even testing for the
part I like cry I was on my way to my
babysitting job in New York and I like
put on dancing queen in my earphones on
the subway and cried I was like and so
when I found out that it actually worked
out it was like it just was a different
a plane of existence yeah I feel like
the books are so iconic
every little girl knows about the Nancy
Drew books did you as a cast and the
Hardy Boys no you're not see I grew up
reading that did you I was gonna say do
any of you guys read the books growing
up or have you gone back since and read
them yeah I didn't third grade like in
the library I couldn't afford the box
set but I read a lot I mean I don't
remember a lot of them because I was in
third grade but I was a huge fan of that
and then when the movie came out with
like Emma Roberts well and the fact that
you have the TV's original Nancy Drew
Pamela sue Martin is a part of the
series yeah what does that mean for you
to have her blessing it was so special
she I mean when she came and shot that
day she had she walked into the makeup
trailer and she's like Kennedy I wrote
you this letter and I was like oh my god
and I went to my trailer and read it and
it's the most darling
she loved us Alden - yes she's so kind
wonderin I'll treasure that that like
forever she was amazing
well I love the fact that this new Nancy
Drew is bringing a fun twist to the
characters that fans know and love let's
do a little character roll call and tell
me a little bit about what we can expect
from your characters art can season one
so obviously Kennedy kick us off with
this Nancy Drew yeah so this Nancy she's
just as she always has been is
incredibly courageous and full of
confidence and meticulous and but we
kind of see a little bit more fire from
her a little bit more command some more
boldness but she's also a flawed in ways
that we haven't seen her represented so
much in the past you know she's growing
up she's becoming an adult and dealing
with a lot of tricky situations like she
needs to work through so best MA then
she from the outside you think that she
is super you know knows what she wants
who she is she she looks very prim and
proper but she's definitely going
through a lot of anxiety for her own
identity and hiding her own secrets - so
through the season you definitely will
see her break down into a really
relatable human being so yeah so I play
George fan previously Georgia Fane and
she is this really tough girl who kind
of comes from a really rough family
definitely a twist on her ex I know in
the book she was not as tough but her
Nancy have got some beef so what's cool
to see them might come together at some
point to have to like solve these
mysteries because I know for a fact
George does not like working with Nancy
but ultimately they kind of have to so
we see that we're gonna see her open up
a little bit mm-hmm and for a fearless
fellas place and he works at the diner
with these ladies and washes dishes and
help solve the crime as he came
there's a lot of comedic moments in the
pilot and what can you tell me about
Nick Nick Ned Nickerson aka Nick
I've been calling myself Nick matters
but know Nick he is he's got a bit of a
past Nick and you kind of find out as
you go we kind of reimagined Ned
Nickerson significantly and as we go
mysteries will be kind of revealed about
what he's got hiding well speaking of
these mysteries I feel like once fans
watched this first episode they're gonna
have so many questions and the first
question that I have is is this a
supernatural series is it a rational one
what do you want to tell the fans yeah
Nancy Leeds with a very anti ghost
mindset and yeah she's she's really not
not having her um but it's a very
supernatural world those are part of it
in there well also we've got to talk
about the fact Kennedy that Scott wolf
is playing your TV dad I love you Scott
where are you a party of five fan
unfortunately passed my time however my
parents are and they were psyched and
they my dad and Scott now they talk all
the time and they're great friends but
Scott's the perfect addition to our
caste he's phenomenal actor phenomenal
person he's awesome I'm so excited for
all the CW fans to crazytown of yours it
definitely gives me some Riverdale vibes
which is great because you guys have
Riverdale leading you guys in now on
Wednesday nights yeah why do you think
that Riverdale fans would enjoy Nancy
Drew I think it's similarly very there's
there's a lot of spook a lot of mystery
a lot of miss you know great
relationships were great romance great
friendships coming together to do things
but I think you know what kind of we
don't take ourselves too seriously I
think these characters all have a really
great sense of humor about everything
and kind
as fast things a little bit of a lighter
level and then dive in for the deeper
moment so I think that kind of contrast
is is going to give a fresh take on this
sort of genre that the CW is used to see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]